Il y a près de 20 ans, la première navette
spatiale américaine, qui avait ouvert la
voie d’un programme aussi important qu’ambitieux,
se désintégrait au dessus du Texas après
une mission scientifique de 16 jours, tuant
7 astronautes. Aujourd’hui, nous revenons
en détail sur la mission, l’accident, et
les récits de ceux dont il a changé le destin
à jamais.
Générique
Nous sommes le 1er février 2003, à Houston.
Au centre de contrôle de la NASA, les contrôleurs
de vol surveillent la rentrée atmosphérique
de la Navette Spatiale Columbia, et ses 7
membres d’équipage, qui reviennent d’une
mission purement scientifique de 16 jours
en orbite basse terrestre. En direct sur CNN,
les journalistes interrompent leurs programmes
pour couvrir l’évènement. Tout semble
correct, mais des alarmes commencent à apparaitre
sur la télémétrie. Les contrôleurs relèvent
que les senseurs de l’aile gauche affichent
des données hors limite au niveau de la température.
Le contact est rompu, comme prévu dans cette
phase, et Houston attend patiemment qu’il
soit rétabli. Au même moment, au bord de
la piste 33 du Kennedy Space Center, c’est
le branle bas de combat. Les véhicules d’assistance
attendent la navette, qui doit arriver à
9h16 précisément, selon les calculs de Houston.
Un double bang supersonique annoncera son
arrivée en Floride, comme à chaque fois,
marquant les derniers freinages de Columbia
avant de se poser. Les familles des astronautes
sont tous présents, dont celles d’Ilan
Ramon, premier astronaute israélien, et fils
de survivants de la shoah. Rona Ramon, la
femme de l’astronaute, raconte : “Dans
les hauts-parleurs, j’ai entendu le Mission
Control dire quelque chose de pas clair. Un
frisson m’a saisi, les cieux se sont obscurcis,
et nous restions là, à sourire. Nous prenions
et photos et nous sourions. Nous étions sur
les bords de la piste, et le compte à rebours
s’égrainait en face de nous, comme lors
du lancement. Tout est silencieux autour de
nous. Trop silencieux. Les dix dernières
secondes s’affichent, et nous les comptons
à voix haute : Dix, neuf, huit, sept… Mais
rien ne se passe. La foule s’agite. Il y
a un silence de mort. On nous demande de nous
rassembler. Les communications ont été perdues,
et la raison n’est pas claire. Des gens
commencent à pleurer. Je regarde le ciel,
et je prie le seigneur qu’il le ramène
à moi. Je demande encore ce qu’il se passe,
mais on ne me répond pas. Le monde entier
savait, mais nous étions encore debout sur
les gradins, à prendre des photos, souriants
et impatients. Le monde entier savait, mais
pas nous.”
Une pluie de débris s’abat sur tout le
Texas. Sur CNN, après quelques minutes de
doutes et d’incompréhension, des images
arrivent du Texas. La chaine WFAA a filmé
ce qui semble être une rentrée atmosphérique
anormale. On annonce alors au Directeur de
vol Leroy Cain ce qu’il est en train de
se passer dans le ciel au dessus d’eux.
Dans un calme olympien, mais ne contenant
que très peu ses larmes, il ordonne de fermer
les portes, ce qui signifie que les données
de tous les postes des controleurs doivent
être sauvegardées et ne doivent être touchées,
pour l’enquête, ce qui est la procédure
en cas d’évènement potentiellement grave.
Au même moment, des habitants de la région
de Palestine appellent CNN et donnent leur
témoignage.
Comme le note le journaliste, “similaire
à Mir”. Norm Thagart, astronaute, ne peut
que confirmer les craintes.
A Houston, la responsable médicale Jackie
Reese prend les contrôleurs à part, loin
de la salle de presse. Pendant plusieurs minutes,
elle les prépare à surmonter psychologiquement
la tragédie. La NASA prépare une conférence
de presse, et informe le président Georges
W Bush.
L’administrateur de la NASA de l’époque,
Sean O’Keefe, raconte : “Le jour de l’accident,
en ce jour si émouvant et difficile, c’est
devenu clair pour moi que l’agenda de la
NASA ne serait plus jamais le même. Tout
l’éventail d’objectifs de gestion et
de grandeur, qu’on avait jusqu’à la veille,
étaient désormais finis. Le chapitre était
clos. Quand j’ai informé le président,
il a immédiatement demandé, et je ne l’oublierai
jamais : “où sont les familles?”. C’était
le premier objectif. S’assurer que les familles
de l’équipage étaient protégées de la
presse et des paparazzis. Il fallait que ce
soit notre priorité, ce jour comme ceux qui
allaient suivre. Le second objectif était
de rassembler tout ce que l’on savait de
l’accident. “Je ne suis pas regardant
sur l’heure, mais il faut être honnête
avec les américains. Dire à tous ce que
l’on sait et répondre honnêtement si l’on
ne sait pas.” disait le président.
Les équipes de recherche et de sauvetage
de Forth Worth, vers Dallas, sont activées.
Les autorités locales établissent des périmètres
de sécurité autour de chaque débris retrouvé.
La NASA prévient les citoyens : S’ils trouvent
un débris, ils ne doivent en aucun cas le
toucher, pour des raisons de sécurité, et
doivent contacter la police ou la NASA directement.
Chaque morceau de la navette sera utile à
l’enquête. En ce qui concerne le sauvetage
des astronautes, il faut se rendre à l’évidence.
A plus de 200 000 pieds d’altitude, à plus
de Mach 16, il n’y a plus aucun espoir de
survie de l’équipage.
16 jours plus tôt, au Kennedy Space Center,
Columbia s’apprête à décoller pour la
28ème fois de son histoire. Son commandant,
Rick Husband, embarque pour son second vol.
Depuis sa tendre enfance, il est passionné
par l’espace, ayant assisté aux vols Mercury,
Gemini et Apollo.
“Voir les atterrissages lunaires, c’était
si inspirant et excitant à mes yeux, que
je me suis dit : “Il n’y a aucun doute
que c’est ce que je voudrai faire quand
je serai grand.””
Dès qu’un avion passe dans le ciel, le
petit Rick Husband ne peut s’empêcher d’arrêter
de jouer et lève les yeux au ciel. Il est
plus que décidé à réaliser son rêve et
va suivre le cursus classique et parfait pour
y parvenir. Diplômé d’ingénierie mécanique,
Second Lieutenant dans l’US Air Force, il
cumule 3800 heures de vol sur plus de 40 modèles
différents d’avion, et devient pilote d’essais
et instructeur. Mais la sélection à la NASA
ne sera pas facile. Après 4 candidatures
et deux entretiens, il est finalement sélectionné
en 1994.
“C’était l’accomplissement d’un rêve
d’une vie. C’est excitant d’enfin faire
le genre de choses que je voulais faire depuis
si longtemps.”
La femme de Rick Husband, Evelyn, raconte
: “Rick était un grand fan de John Young,
donc quand celui-ci lui parlait, Rick notait
tout et archivait le calepin car il disait
que c’était profond et intéressant. Une
des choses que John Young a confié à Rick
était : “Ne donne pas tout à la NASA.
Ils prendront ton âme si tu les laisse faire.”
Cela venait de quelqu’un qui avait travaillé
pour la NASA pendant des décennies, marché
sur la Lune, et vécu une longue vie, et c’était
un très bon conseil que Rick a pris à coeur,
et je pense que ce conseil s’applique aussi
aux épouses d’astronautes.”
Son rêve se concrétise le 27 mais 1999,
sur la mission STS-96 où il est le pilote
de la navette Discovery. Pendant 9 jours,
il goute aux joies du vol spatial, et a l’honneur
de piloter la navette vers la toute naissante
Station Spatiale Internationale pour la première
mission de ravitaillement de celle-ci. C’est
aussi le premier amarrage officiel d’une
navette à la station. Quelques jours après
son retour sur Terre, il apprend qu’il commandera
STS-107.
“Il m’a raconté à quel point son équipage
était génial, il a énuméré chacun d’entre
eux et m’a tout raconté à propos d’eux
et leurs familles. Il m’a aussi dit qui
ils étaient, en tant que personne.”
Quelques jours avant le décollage, Rick Husband
entre dans une période de quarantaine. Très
attaché à sa famille, ses enfants ont du
mal à le savoir loin. Pour rester virtuellement
auprès d’eux, l’astronaute enregistre
une vidéo pour chaque jour qu’il passera
dans l’espace. Chaque matin, les enfants
recevaient une cassette pré enregistrée
de leur père, leur disant qu’il était
fier d’eux, qu’ils lui manquaient, et
qu’il reviendrait bientôt. Fervant chrétien,
croyant et très pratiquant, il n’a pour
autant aucun problème à fédérer un équipage
aux croyances et origines différentes comme
celui de STS-107.
“Rick était capable de partager sa foi
sans prosélytisme, y compris avec des personnes
de fois et cultures différentes. Il était
capable d’en parler de façon intime sans
que quiconque ne se dise “oh non, il essaie
vraiment de me convaincre de croire les mêmes
choses que lui… Rick avait juste le don
de partager sa foi sans offenser celle des
autres.”
A ses côtés dans le cockpit se trouve William
McCool, au poste de pilote de Columbia. C’est
son premier vol spatial. Détenteur d’un
diplôme en science appliquée, d’un master
en sciences de l’informatique et d’un
autre master en ingéniérie astronautique,
il s’engage ensuite dans l’US Navy, et
devient pilote embarqué sur les porte avions
USS Coral Sea et USS Enterprise, totalisant
plus de 400 appontages et 2800 heures de vol.
Particulièrement intéressé par l’aspect
scientifique de la mission, il dira :
“Tout ce qu’on fait là-haut, c’est
créer des technologies pour le futur. Ceux
qui les utiliseront et les feront évoluer
sont les enfants d’aujourd’hui. Il n’y
a pas de plus grande expérience, en tout
cas dans ma carrière, que de voir la joie
et le rêve dans les yeux des enfants quand
on leur parle de nos expériences.”
Attaché à sa famille comme son commandant,
il aime particulièrement les randonnées
avec sa femme et ses enfants. Il a promi a
Lani, son épouse photographe, qu’à son
retour, il l’aiderait à terminer un livre
de photographies. Avec lui, il emporte dans
l’espace leurs deux alliances et des photos
de leur mariage.
Tout comme Rick Husband, le Specialiste de
Mission David Brown a toujours rêvé de devenir
astronaute. Et tout comme William McCool,
ce sera son premier vol spatial.
“Je suis né un peu tard pour Mercury, mais
je me souviens de Gemini et Apollo, suivi
de Skylab et les premiers vols de navette.
Mais je n’arrivais pas à m’identifier
aux astronautes. Je les voyais comme des stars
de cinéma, je n’étais qu’un gamin comme
les autres. Je ne voyais donc pas comment
un gamin normal comme moi pouvait un jour
être comme ces gens. Forcément, même si
je pensais que c’était le job le plus cool
qui existe, ce n’était pas du tout quelque
chose que j’imaginais faire un jour.”
Il obtient un diplôme en biologie, un doctorat
en médecine, et intègre l’US Navy en tant
que médecin de vol. Il est le premier médecin
de vol de la Navy à devenir pilote embarqué
en 1990. Il totalise 1700 heures de vol avant
d’être sélectionné comme astronaute de
la NASA.
La Spécialiste de Mission Kalpana Chawla
est la première femme astronaute d’origine
indienne. Née à Karnal, en inde, elle y
fait ses études et obtient en 1982 son diplôme
en ingéniérie aéronautique. Elle déménage
ensuite aux Etats-Unis pour intégrer l’Université
de Texas-Arlington. Elle y décroche un master
en ingéniérie aérospatiale et est engagée
par la NASA au centre Ames. Après une brillante
mais courte carrière dans le domaine de l’aérodynamique,
elle est sélectionnée par la NASA comme
astronaute en 1994. Elle réalise son premier
vol sur STS-87 en temps que spécialiste de
mission, où elle a l’occasion de manipuler
le bras robotique de la navette Columbia.
“Il faisait nuit en Inde au moment du lancement,
mais ils étaient tous levés pour le regarder.
Ils avaient organisé des retraites aux flambeaux,
c’était comme un jour de fête nationale.
La ville avait décoré ma maison natale avec
des guirlandes. Mon décollage était important
pour l’Inde. J’étais impressionnée car
je ne m’attendais pas à tant d’engouement.”
Passionnée d’aviation depuis l’enfance,
elle aime particulièrement emmener son mari
en vol. Elle détient sa license d’instructrice
de vol civile sur avions et planeurs, mais
également les licences de pilote privée
et commerciale. Quand on lui demande, avant
STS-107, quelles figures l’ont motivée
à suivre cette carrière, elle répondra
:
“Dans mon cas, je pense que la motivation
et l’inspiration viennent tous les jours
des personnes que je croise. C’est facile
pour moi d’être motivée et inspirée en
voyant quelqu’un qui donne tout pour arriver
à un résultat. Par exemple, certains professeurs
dans les écoles. L’effort énorme qu’ils
font pour présenter un cours. Le temps supplémentaire
qu’ils allouent pour faire des expériences
avec nous. Ensuite, les compliments qu’ils
donnent à leurs élèves pour avoir présenté
de nouvelles idées… Bref, je me demande
toujours où ils trouvent la patience de faire
tout ça.”
Michael Anderson, Specialiste de Mission,
réalise son second vol avec STS-107. Fils
d’aviateur, il baigne dans l’aviation
dès sa plus tendre enfance. Diplômé en
physique et astronomie, il s’engage ensuite
dans l’Air Force, où il totalise 3000 heures
de vol sur KC-135 et T-38. Il est recruté
comme astronaute en 1994, et réalise son
premier vol sur STS-89, une mission à destination
de la station Mir.
“Je suis sûrement différent des autres
astronautes, car je n’aime pas du tout les
décollages. Je trouve que les lancements
sont d’horribles manières d’aller dans
l’espace. Mais actuellement, c’est la
meilleure manière qu’on a d’y aller.
En fait, c’est même la seule. Mais une
fois qu’on arrive en orbite et qu’on est
dans l’espace, c’est là que je me mets
au travail et que je transforme cette fusée
en laboratoire orbital.”
Passionné d’automobile, il est perçu comme
assez introverti, sauf quand on le lance sur
deux sujets : sa famille, et sa Porsche. Sa
vie privée est très réservée. Peu de personnes
dans son entourage savent qu’il est astronaute,
et c’est une chose qui lui va bien. Pour
le reste, c’est un accroc du travail, qui
a du mal à garder du temps pour sa femme
et ses deux enfants, malgré l’amour qu’il
leur porte.
Laurel Clark est Spécialiste de mission sur
STS-107. Contrairement à ses coéquipiers,
l’aviation et l’espace ne faisaient pas
partie de ses rêves d’enfant.
“Je me suis intéressée aux mission lunaires
comme tous les gens de ma génération, mais
je n’ai jamais vraiment voulu devenir astronaute
ou travailler dans l’espace. Je m’intéressais
plutôt à l’environnement, les écosystèmes
et les animaux.“
C’est donc tout naturellement qu’elle
suit un cursus en zoologie, et obtient un
doctorat de médecine. Tout comme David Brown,
elle devient médecin dans l’US Navy, mais
pas sur un porte avions. Son environnement
sera sous l’eau, auprès des plongeurs et
des équipages de sous marins.
“C’était pour moi une progression naturelle
quand j’ai appris ce que les astronautes
de la NASA faisaient, et le genre de choses
qu’ils devaient accomplir. J’ai pensé
aux choses que j’avais faites jusque là
et cette suite de carrière m’intéressait.”
Elle est sélectionnée par la NASA en 1996.
Il faudra attendre 2003 pour son premier vol,
STS-107. Quelques mois plus tôt, Laurel Clark
et sa famille sont victimes d’un accident
d’avion à l’atterrissage. L’avion fut
détruit, mais la famille entière s’en
sont sortis indemnes. Iain, le fils de Jon
et Laurel Clark, encore sous le choc, redoutait
qu’il arrive quelque chose à sa mère lors
de son vol spatial. Il l’a supplie de ne
pas partir sur cette mission. Elle ne renonce
pas. Elle dira :
“Un navire est en sécurité au port. Mais
ce n’est pas la raison d’être d’un
navire.”
Ilan Ramon est un ancien pilote de chasse
de l’armée Israélienne. A l’âge de
23 ans, il avait écrit au Professeur Yeshayahu
Leibowitz, scientifique et philosophe, des
questions sur le sens de la vie. Il écrivait
: “A quoi bon mourir pour son pays? Est-ce
que donner ma vie pour un autre changera quoi
que ce soit dans le monde?” Son expérience
en combat et la mise en danger de sa vie pour
la guerre ne lui plaisait plus. Il avait envie
de servir une cause plus noble. “Est-ce
la vie que l’on veut? Un jour, tout se terminera.
Nous serons à court de soldats. L’objectif
est de vivre, de vivre en paix. Y arriverons-nous?”
Recruté comme premier astronaute israélien,
il s’investit pleinement dans la mission
STS-107, et les nombreuses expériences scientifiques
qu’il va devoir accomplir. Dans son journal,
il écrit : “Qui aurait cru que je serait
le premier israélien à survoler la Terre
et mon pays? ”
Le Research Double Module, ou RDM, va faire
son vol inaugural sur STS-107. Conçu par
les américains de la firme Spacehab, il est
assez similaire au Spacelab conçu par les
européens et sert les mêmes objectifs : offrir
un lieu dédié aux expériences en orbite,
transformant la navette en véritable laboratoire
spatial. Spacehab avait déjà fourni à la
NASA le Single Module, au concept similaire
mais très limité en taille. Le RDM promet
comme son nom l’indique de doubler cet espace
pour maximiser les expériences scientifiques.
Lors de STS-107, les astronautes vont se relayer
24 heures sur 24 pour les réaliser, à la
manière des missions spatiales scientifiques
précédentes. Comme d’habitude pour ce
genre de mission, on divise l’équipage
en deux équipes, la rouge et la bleue. Dans
la rouge, Husband, Chawla, Clark et Ramon,
et dans la Bleue, McCool, Brown et Anderson.
Parmi les 59 expériences à l’intérieur
du Spacehab, 21 sont commanditées par des
firmes privées, 14 pour l’Agence Spatiale
Européenne, une au profit de la Station Spatiale
Internationale, et 23 pour l’OBPR, le Bureau
de Recherche en Médecine et Biologie de la
NASA. L’utilité de certaines est capitale.
On peut citer l’expérience MGM qui va compresser
des materiaux granuleux en apesanteur dans
l’espoir d’améliorer les techniques de
construction, en particulier pour les fondations
de bâtiments en zones sensibles aux tremblements
de terre, inondations et glissements de terrain.
Une autre vise à étudier des cristaux de
protéines dans le but de mettre au point
d’éventuelles thérapies pour prévenir
de la formation de certains cancers et de
calmer leurs symptômes. En dehors du module
pressurisé, des expériences sont stockées
dans la soute et exposées à l’espace,
et ne requiereront pas d’intervention de
l’équipage. Elles sont placées sur le
toit du Spacehab, mais aussi sur les palettes
externes Hitchhiker et EDO. Au total, ce sont
pas moins de 80 expériences qui vont se dérouler
à l’intérieur comme à l’extérieur
de la navette pendant 2 semaines en orbite,
dont certains initiées par des écoles d’Australie,
de Chine, d’Israel, du Japon, des Etats-Unis
et du Liechtenstein.
Même si l’entrainement aux systèmes de
la navette et aux expériences scientifiques
est primordial, la façon même dont la mission
est conçue impose à l’équipage d’être
soudé malgré les problèmes qui pourraient
survenir en orbite. En 1985, Taylor Wang s’envole
pour sa première mission spatiale, STS-51B.
L’objectif principal est de réaliser des
expériences sur le Spacelab, un module d’expériences
placé dans la soute. Après le lancement,
tout semble aller, excepté pour l’expérience
que doit faire Taylor Wang, qui refuse de
fonctionner. La pression sur lui est énorme,
puisque, bien qu’américain, il est le premier
astronaute d’origine chinoise dans l’espace.
Avec ce stress, ajouté au mal de l’espace
et l’impossibilité de réaliser son expérience,
Wang développe une grave dépression. Selon
Mike Mullane, astronaute de la NASA, les toilettes
de la navette sont ensuite tombé en panne,
ce qui forçait l’équipage à revenir à
la bonne vieille technique d’Apollo : faire
ses besoins dans des sacs, en s’aidant de
leurs mains gantées. Taylor Wang a alors
trouvé une solution : il refusait de faire
ses besoins. Pendant plusieurs jours, ils
se retient et refuse de manger quoi que ce
soit de solide, ce qui aggrave son état psychique.
Inquiets, ses collègues n’arriveront pas
à le rassurer, et même si son expérience
finira par fonctionner, il ne retournera plus
jamais dans l’espace. C’est justement
suite à ce précédent, et d’autres, que
la NASA insiste sur la cohésion des équipages,
et pour STS-107, organise une sortie en nature
de 10 jours dans la National Outdoor Leadership
School, un camp dans les Montagnes Rocheuses.
Au programme, des tentes partagées, de la
nourriture rationnée, pas de téléphone,
et de l’eau purifiée. En réalité, ce
stage a de nombreuses similarités avec le
vol spatial. Comme durant le vol, ils doivent
résoudre des problèmes avec seulement le
contenu de leur sac à dos, se laver d’une
façon plus que spartiate, et bien prendre
soin de leurs affaires. Ce séjour en forêt
leur permet également de découvrir les forces
et faiblesses de chacun, de mieux se connaître,
et bien sûr d’éviter les conflits qui
pourraient poser des problèmes durant la
mission. Les guides locaux assistent l’équipage
sur les premiers jours de randonnée, mais
se retirent ensuite et les laissent se guider
eux-même. Chaque jour, un membre d’équipage
différent prend la direction des opérations,
et ce chef du jour est évalué par les autres
en fin de journée.
Le lancement est initialement prévu pour
aout 2001, mais à l’instar de la majorité
des lancements de navette, STS-107 va subir
d’importants retards. Au retour de STS-93,
Columbia est envoyée en Californie pour subir
des travaux de maintenance et d’amélioration
importants, estimés à plus de 160 millions
de dollars. La navette revient en Floride
comme neuve, mais en retard sur le programme
initial. Plus vieille navette de la flotte,
elle est également la plus lourde, ce qui
l’exclut des missions d’assemblage de
la Station Spatiale Internationale. Seules
2 missions lui sont donc assignées avant
sa retraite définitive : STS-107, mission
scientifique, et STS-109, pour réparer Hubble.
Le télescope, qui subit une série de malfonctions
au début des années 2000, va donc devenir
la priorité de la NASA. STS-109 va donc partir
avant STS-107, ce qui retarde encore cette
dernière. Columbia revient de sa maintenance
d’Hubble en mars 2002, et retourne au hangar
pour être préparée à sa toute dernière
mission. On lui retire son bras robotique,
la plateforme d’amarrage du télescope,
et on installe le laboratoire Spacehab. L’opération
est assez rapide, et on estime alors que le
lancement de STS-107 pourrait avoir lieu en
juillet 2002. Cette fois, en juin, c’est
un problème potentiellement grave qui va
à nouveau entrainer un report. Des fissures
sont repérées au niveau des moteurs principaux
d’autres navettes de la flotte, ce qui implique
un démontage complet de tous les moteurs
pour inspection. D’autres missions volent
tandis que Columbia est au sol, et une fois
les moteurs inspectés et les fissures comblées,
ce sont d’autres fissures sur d’autres
composants qui imposent d’autres inspections
et réparations. Les mois passent, au plus
grand bonheur de l’équipage, qui en profite
pour passer du temps avec leurs familles et
parfaire leur entrainement à la mission.
Les autorités américaines sont particulièrement
soucieuses de la sécurité entourant ce lancement,
en raison de la présence d’un Israélien
à bord, et l’atmosphère menaçante qui
suit les attentats du 11 septembre. En plus
de la date de lancement, qui sera annoncé
au dernier moment, les astronautes et leurs
familles sont sous escorte constante, et en
Floride, les véhicules sont soumis à des
fouilles et contrôles réguliers par les
militaires américains. La soute est définitivement
fermée le 31 octobre 2002, et la navette
est ensuite rattachée au réservoir externe
et aux boosters, avant d’être amenée sur
le pas de tir 39A, en Décembre. Le 16 janvier
2003, Columbia est prête et ses astronautes
s’installent à bord. Husband, McCool, Brown
et Chawla se placent dans cockpit, tandis
qu’Anderson, Clark et Ramon sont dans le
pont inférieur. Ces trois astronautes n’auront
donc pas le luxe de voir le lancement, les
hublots étant absent à leur niveau. A 10h39
heure locale, Columbia s’élance à destination
de l’orbite, pour la dernière fois de sa
longue carrière.
Le décollage, en apparence, s’est passé
à merveille. Cependant, des ingénieurs tirent
la sonnette d’alarme sur un impact de débris,
sûrement de mousse, sur l’aile gauche de
Columbia. Ils espèrent qu’une inspection
visuelle pourra être réalisée par les astronautes.
En attendant, l’équipage ouvre la soute
rapidement, et active les systèmes du laboratoire
orbital. Le travail commence vite, et bien.
Un seul petit problème survient. Un des deux
déshumidifacteurs permettant de récupérer
et rediriger de l’eau dans le Spacehab produit
des étincelles, une situation qu’il est
préférable d’éviter dans l’espace.
Le problème est vite résolu, et l’équipage,
désormais divisé en deux équipes, suivent
le lourd programme d’expériences scientifiques
qui les occuperont 24 heures sur 24 pendant
les 16 prochains jours. En parrallèle, sur
Terre, des ingénieurs de la NASA se réunissent
et échangent des emails au sujet de l’impact
de mousse sur l’aile gauche. Certains d’entre
eux font des demandes auprès du Département
de la Défense américain pour que des satellites
espions photographient la navette, ce qui
a déjà eu lieu lors de missions précédentes,
mais les hauts responsables de la NASA estiment
que ce serait superflu. La NASA n’a visiblement
pas non plus envie de connaitre l’étendue
des dégats, vu qu’il est de toute façon
impossible de faire quoi que ce soit pour
ramener l’équipage autrement qu’à bord
de Columbia. Le 23 janvier, le directeur de
vol Steve Stitch informe l’équipage de
l’impact : “Il n’y a aucune inquiétude
à avoir en ce qui concerne le RCC ou des
dommages sur les tuiles. Nous avons vu ça
sur d’autres vols et ça ne posera pas de
problème pour la rentrée.” Le RCC, c’est
le bord d’attaque de l’aile en carbon
renforcé. Il est notamment utilisé pour
les disques de freins des formule 1, et même
du concorde. Cette partie est considérée
par les astronautes comme invulnérable tant
elle est résistante. A ce moment précis,
la NASA a peu d’informations sur la zone
d’impact, et pense que le débris de mousse
pourrait avoir frappé les tuiles placées
sous l’aile, et au vu de l’angle, pourrait
n’avoir fait que des dégâts mineurs. Le
RCC, bien que mentionné lors des réunions,
est selon eux sûrement intact.
Pendant les jours qui suivent, le quotidien
à bord est routinier. La Red Team et la Blue
Team se relaient sur les expériences en continu,
les astronautes profitent de la vue, et communiquent
avec leurs familles. Le 27 janvier, ils ont
également l’occasion de discuter quelques
minutes avec les 3 astronautes de l’Expedition
6 à bord de la Station Spatiale Internationale.
Sur une orbite bien différente, les américains
Ken Bowersox et Don Pettit, et le russe Nikolai
Budarin occupent la station depuis deux mois.
Le lendemain, 28 janvier, c’est le Remembrance
Day, en l’honneur des astronautes décédés
lors d’Apollo 1 et Challenger. A cette occasion,
ils leur rendent hommage depuis l’orbite.
Le 29 janvier 2003, l’équipage est réveillé
par la chanson Imagine de John Lennon. William
McCool, après avoir écouté sa chanson préférée,
dira : “De notre unique point de vue en
orbite, nous observons la Terre sans frontières,
paisible et magnifique, et nous prions pour
que l’humanité imagine un monde comme nous
le voyons actuellement, sans frontières,
et ayant le désir de vivre uni et en paix.”
Les expériences sont un vrai succès, mais
au sol, des ingénieurs continuent à débattre
des potentiels dommages de l’aile gauche,
et des procédures possibles dans le cas où
la chaleur endommage le système de déploiement
du train principal gauche. La NASA ne prend
aucune décision ferme.
Le 30 janvier, les préparations du retour
sur Terre commencent. Progressivement, les
expériences sont éteintes et leurs résultats
stockés ou transmis vers la Terre. David
Brown écrit un dernier email à ses parents
: “Le moment le plus émouvant pour moi,
c’est quand j’ai lu une lettre qu’Ilan
Ramon a emmené à bord, écrite par un survivant
de l’Holocauste dont la fille de 7 ans avait
perdu la vie. J’étais choqué du fait que
des choses si horribles pouvaient arriver
sur une si belle planète.”
Le 1er février 2003, la navette effectue
sa rentrée dans l’atmosphère. Evelyn Husband
attend son mari sur la piste du Kennedy Space
Center.
“Une minute avant l’heure prévue d’atterrissage,
j’ai demandé à Steve Lindsey, astronaute
escorte des familles : Steve, dans quelle
direction ils vont arriver? Steve avait un
regard vraiment étrange, clairement pas le
genre que je voulais voir à ce moment-là.
Il a pointé une direction dans le ciel, puis
a décroché son téléphone. Ensuite, le
compte à rebours de retour a indiqué 0,
et je savais que j’aurais déjà du entendre
les bangs supersoniques à T-1 minute. Mais
c’était le silence total sur la piste.
J’ai commencé à avoir peur. J’ai regardé
Steve et je lui ai demandé : “Quand vont-ils
se poser? Pourquoi il n’y a pas eu de bangs?”
Mais il était toujours au téléphone. Tous
les responsables étaient au téléphone,
à se lever et courir de partout. Mes enfants,
Laura et Matthew me tiennent la main, et me
demandent si leur père va bien. Je me rappelle
m’être retournée vers Keith, le frère
de Rick, pour lui demander pourquoi on avait
pas entendu les bangs. Il m’a répondu qu’il
n’y en aurait pas. Il savait déjà, et
la mère de Rick s’est éffrondée, et moi
aussi.”
Après son discours d’annonce de l’accident
à la nation, le Président Bush place le
Texas en zone sinistrée afin de faciliter
les recherches de débris. Une commission
d’enquête est créée, le CAIB, pour Columbia
Accident Investigation Board. En 2003, le
contexte international est particulier. Cela
fait un an et demi que le pays a été frappé
à New York et au Pentagone, la Guerre en
Afghanistan fait rage, et l’Irak est sur
le point d’être envahi. Avec un astronaute
israélien à bord, la piste terroriste est
évoquée, mais vite écartée. Au vu de la
hauteur et la vitesse de la navette, aucun
missile n’aurait pu l’intercepter. L’impact
de la mousse isolante sur l’aile gauche
est très vite pointée du doigt comme la
possible cause de l’accident, mais pour
faire la lumière sur le déroulé précis
des évènements, il est primordial de continuer
à collecter les débris. Des bénévoles
se joignent aux recherches, tandis que d’autres
retrouvent et tentent de vendre des débris
sur Ebay. Un élément en particulier de Columbia,
présent sur aucune autre navette, pourrait
aider à résoudre le mystère de l’accident
: l’enregistreur OEX. Cet instrument, qui
enregistre les données de plus de 570 capteurs
de la navette, peut être considéré comme
la boite noire de Columbia. Présent sur aucune
autre navette, il a été installé à l’époque
des tous premiers vols de l’orbiteur, en
1981, pour évaluer les performances de vol.
D’autres restes vont se révéler déterminants.
Durant les premiers jours de recherche, Carl
Vita et Marty Pontecorvo vont trouver une
cassete vidéo près de Palestine, au Texas.
A Houston, sa lecture va émouvoir l’ensemble
de la communauté spatiale. On y voit l’équipage
durant la rentrée atmosphérique, filmé
par Laurel Clark. Ces 13 minutes montrent
les astronautes qui rient, échangent des
commentaires sur le spectacle de la rentrée
atmosphérique, tout en déroulant leur checklist.
La vidéo s’arrête une quinzaine de minutes
avant l’accident. Cette vidéo, même si
elle ne montre pas ce qui s’est passé durant
la désintégration de la navette, permet
aux enquêteurs de voir l’état émotionnel
des astronautes, un facteur important. Rendu
public, ce document montre, encore aujourd’hui,
les dernières images de l’équipage avant
leur décès.
Le 18 mars 2003, Art Baker explore un terrain
vallonné près de Hemphill, au Texas, quand
il trouve le fameux enregistreur OEX. Dans
un état remarquable, il est emballé avec
précaution et envoyé au Minnesota pour être
nettoyé, puis transféré au Kennedy Space
Center avec toujours autant de soin. Il termine
son voyage à Houston, où son contenu va
être décodé et analysé en détail. L’enregistreur
a pu recueillir des informations précises
sur tous les systèmes jusqu’à 9h, 0 minutes
et 18 secondes, ce qui correspond au moment
exact où les témoins au sol ont constaté
les premiers signes de désintégration de
la navette. Il est désormais clair que les
données de l’OEX seront déterminantes
pour clore l’enquête.
Durant les recherches de débris qui prennent
plusieurs mois, des hélicoptères quadrillent
la zone, dont celui de Jules Mier et Charles
Krenek, employés du Service Forestier National
Américain. Le 27 mars 2003, alors qu’ils
survolent la zone de recherche à basse altitude,
leur moteur se coupe. A moins de 40 mètres
du sol, au ras des arbres, les deux pilotes
ne peuvent rien faire. L’hélicoptère s’écrase
dans une forêt de Broddus. Les deux pilotes
sont tués sur le coup, et leurs trois passagers,
employés respectivement de United Space Alliance,
le Service Forestier et la NASA, sont blessés.
Krenek et Mier seront les huitième et neuvième
victimes de Columbia.
Pendant ce temps, en Floride, le hangar RLV,
bâti pour préparer les navettes X-33 à
leurs missions, est réaffecté par la NASA
pour l’enquête de STS-107. On trace au
sol des carrés, et on dispose les débris
de façon à reconstituer Columbia. Au total,
ce sont plus de 83 000 morceaux de différentes
tailles qui vont arriver dans le hangar, récupérés
au 4 coins du Texas et de ses états voisins,
de février à mai 2003. Cela équivaut à
38% seulement de la navette, mais certains
de ces débris s’avèrent important pour
l’enquête, comme les RCC, les tuiles, ou
encore les panneaux et interrupteurs du cockpit.
Dans le RLV, une ingénieure de la NASA prend
le travail de reconstruction tout particulièrement
à coeur. Son nom : Ann Micklos. Elle a entretenu
une relation amoureuse avec l’astronaute
David Brown pendant 3 ans. Dans le hangar,
elle est responsable de l’équipe de reconstruction
des tuiles de Columbia.
“C’était à la fois personnel et professionnel
pour moi, et je voulais comprendre ce qui
c’était passé. Comme moi, les gens dans
le hangar étaient détachés émotionnellement,
mais c’était difficile de voir ça. Les
premiers morceaux reçus étaient les plus
humanisants, comme les cadres de hublots.
Jamais on n’aurait imaginé que c’est
de cette façon que la navette nous reviendrait.
C’était dur, mais c’était nécessaire,
afin de traverser ces émotions et tourner
la page.”
On retrouve également des restes des astronautes
et de leurs combinaisons, ce qui permet de
mener des autopsies et mieux comprendre les
derniers instants de l’équipage. Au fil
des semaines, la commission d’enquête se
concentre de plus en plus sur la problématique
des débris frappant la navette au décollage,
fragilisant le bouclier thermique. Ils vont
alors reprendre l’historique des vols de
navette, à la recherche de précédents,
puis étudier le bord d’attaque de l’aile,
les panneaux RCC.
Après l’accident de Challenger qui a couté
la vie à 7 astronautes en 1986, les missions
navette reprennent. STS-26 ouvre le bal à
nouveau en 1988, puis STS-27. Durant la phase
d’ascension, l’équipage voit des morceaux
blancs frapper les vitres du cockpit. Une
inspection est réalisée par des caméras
sur le bras robotique, mais vu que cette mission
est pour le compte de la défense américaine,
les images reçues par les ingénieurs de
la NASA sont en partie brouillées et ils
considèrent que ce ne sont pas des dégats
sévères. En réalité, une partie de l’isolation
des SRB a frappé la navette au décollage,
et le commandant de la mission, inquiet, informe
les contrôleurs au sol qu’il ne manquera
pas de dire ce qu’il pense de leurs conclusions
optimistes s’il constate que la navette
est sur le point de bruler lors de la rentrée.
Le 6 décembre 1988, Atlantis revient en un
seul morceau au sol, mais les dégats sont
considérables : 700 tuiles sont gravement
endomagées, et une tuile manque. Heureusement,
sous la protection thermique manquante, une
plaque d’aluminium presque totalement fondue
a empêché la navette de se vaporiser. Un
incident a été évité, et de peu. La commission
se penche ensuite sur les RCC. On reconstruit
dans un hangar de bord d’attaque de Columbia,
sur lequel on projette de la mousse isolante
à grande vitesse. Le résultat surprend tout
le monde.
Charles Bolden, ancien pilote de navette et
ancien administrateur de la NASA, parlera
des RCC : “Jamais dans ma mémoire, et même
en fouillant dans mes notes, jamais nous n’avons
parlé des RCC, le bord d’attaque de l’aile,
celui de la dérive, ou même le bout de nez.
Personne n’a jamais réfléchi à la possibilité
d’avoir des dégâts sur ces parties parce
que nous pensions tous qu’elles étaient
impénétrables. En réalité, ce n’est
que quand on a perdu Columbia que j’ai appris
à quel point c’était fin. J’ai grandi
dans le programme spatial, j’ai passé 14
ans à voler dans ce programme, tout en pensant
que le bord d’attaque était une masse épaisse
de 10 ou 15 centimètres. Et quand j’ai
appris, après l’accident de Columbia, que
ce n’était que des fractions d’à peine
2 centimètres d’épaisseur, et qu’elles
n’étaient pas plus resistantes que la fibre
de verre d’une carrosserie de voiture, ça
nous a ouvert les yeux.”
La lumière est alors faite sur le déroulé
précis de l’accident. Le 1er février 2003,
la navette fait une poussée de désorbitation
et commence sa descente à travers l’atmosphère.
Vu que Columbia fait sa rentrée de l’Ouest
jusqu’à l’est des états unis, des passionnés
ont leurs caméras braquées dans le ciel
dans tous les états du sud. 4 minutes après
le début de la rentrée atmosphérique, alors
que l’équipage filme les flammes tout à
fait normales à travers les vitres du cockpit,
des débris sont éjectés de l’aile droite
et sont vus par des témoins au sol observant
la rentrée depuis la cote ouest. Une minute
après, les contrôleurs à houston perdent
le contact avec 4 capteurs de température
sur l’aile gauche. Sans que personne ne
le sache, l’aile gauche est en train de
lentement se désintégrer.
La navette survole le Nevada, l’utah, l’Arizona,
puis commence une série de manoeuvres prévues
qui se déroulent parfaitement. Elle entre
au nouveau mexique, et au sol, le télescope
Starfire de l’US Air Force enregistre cette
photo infrarouge, révélant une anomalie
sur l’aile gauche. L’ordinateur engage
le compensateur de l’aileron pour tenter
de corriger l’assymétrie du flux aérodynamique.
Au bout de 4 minutes, une faible compensation
ne suffit plus et devient maximale.
Au même moment, la chaleur est telle à l’intérieur
de l’aile gauche que les capteurs de température
n’affiche plus aucune information. Les astronautes
reçoivent une alerte indiquant la perte des
pateurs de pression du train gauche. Les compensateurs
de l’aileron n’arrivant pas à compenser
l’assymétrie, les RCS à l’arrière droit
s’activent pour aider à corriger la trajectoire.
Leur poussée devient continue, mais ne suffit
toujours pas. A Houston, on informe l’équipage
des problèmes de capteurs sur l’aile gauche.
Ce moment coincide avec la perte de contact
attendue lors de la rentrée.
Columbia entre au dessus du Texas à 16 fois
la vitesse du son. Des tuiles continuent à
se détacher. Un troisième propulseur RCS
s’active pour compenser l’asymétrie,
puis un quatrième. Houston ne peut pas communiquer
avec l’équipage, et ne reçoit aucune donnée
de la navette. Le système hydraulique, touché
par la chaleur dans l’aile, se rompt totalement.
Le nez de la navette se lève, et le contrôle
n’est plus possible. Columbia entre dans
une vrille à plat. A ce moment-là, un des
astronautes sur le pont inférieur termine
les préparations d’atterrissage, et tente
de s’attacher à son siège. Les astronautes
avaient à ce moment-là leurs visières de
casques relevées, comme la procédure le
veut, et certains n’avaient pas encore mit
leurs gants. Le pilote et le commandant, incapables
de corriger la trajectoire, passe la navette
en pilotage automatique, ce qui n’aura aucun
effet. L’équipage n’aura pas le temps
d’enfiler leurs gants et baisser leurs visières.
Peu de temps après, l’aile gauche, puis
les portes de la soute s’arrachent, augmentant
la fragilité générale du corps central
de Columbia. Avec la chaleur s’engouffrant
dans la soute et les contraintes aérodynamiques,
l’avant du fuselage se sépare du reste
de la navette au niveau de la soute. Les deux
ponts du cockpit sont dépressurisés, les
lumières s’éteignent, et les astronautes,
non protégés, perdent connaissance presque
immédiatement. Plus aucun membre d’équipage
ne respire désormais, et plus rien n’est
possible pour les réanimer à ce stade. L’avant
de la navette tourne lentement sur lui même,
et les attaches des astronautes ne fonctionnent
pas suffisament bien pour les maintenir fermement.
Les secousses infligent aux astronautes des
blessures létales. La chaleur s’engoufre
désormais dans tous les interstices de la
partie avant de la navette. L’enregistreur
de données cesse de fonctionner, et la partie
avant finit de totalement se désintégrer.
Après l’accident, la flotte de navettes
est clouée au sol. Ce passage à vide impactera
particulièrement la construction de la Station
Spatiale Internationale, qui dépend principalement
des orbiteurs américains pour transporter
et installer les nouveaux modules et structures.
Cette pause se terminera en juillet 2005,
avecune condition cependant : Les vols se
concentreront uniquement sur les livraisons
de modules pour la station spatiale internationale,
et la maintenance du télescope spatial Hubble.
STS-107 sera donc la toute dernière mission
scientifique orbitale de l’histoire des
navettes spatiales. Trois nouvelles procédures
naissent également suite à l’accident
de Columbia : D’abord, les navettes reçoivent
un nouvel outil, l’OBSS, une extension du
bras robotique, lui permettant une fois en
orbite de scruter le bouclier thermique et
le fuselage dans le moindre détail à la
recherches d’éventuels dommages. Ensuite,
chaque navette se rendant sur l’ISS doit
effectuer une sorte de salto appelée Rendez-Vous
Pitch manoeuver, de façon à ce que les astronautes
de la station filment et photographient la
navette sous tous les angles. Les images sont
transmises au sol et s’il y a des tuiles
manquantes ou d’autres dommages, Houston
peut diriger une sortie extra véhiculaire
pour réparer tout dommage. Enfin, on met
en place les missions STS-3xx et 400. Pour
la plupart des lancements de navette qui ont
lieu après l’accident de Columbia, une
autre est présente sur le pas de tir voisin,
avec un équipage prêt à décoller. Cela
permet, si la navette n’est pas réparable,
de partir récupérer l’équipage et de
le ramener sur Terre à bord de la navette
de secours. Ces missions ne seront jamais
réalisées, mais l’une d’elle, STS-400,
restera comme la plus connue. Lors de la dernière
visite auprès du télescope Hubble, Atlantis
se trouve sur une orbite bien différente
de celle de l’ISS, ce qui rend son sauvetage
impossible si des dégâts sont repérés
sur le bouclier. La mission STS-400 est donc
mise sur pied. La navette Endeavour, sur le
pas de tir 39B, se tient prête à aller secourir
les astronautes de STS-125 en cas de problème.
Heureusement, Atlantis n’aura aucun dégat
au décollage, et sera en mesure de terminer
sa mission sur Hubble. Toutes ces nouvelles
précautions vont tout de même montrer leur
utilité dès le retour en vol des navettes,
en 2005. Lors du vol STS-114, premier vol
d’une navette après l’accident de Columbia,
d’autres morceaux de mousse se détachent
du réservoir externe et l’un d’eux frappe
l’aile droite de Discovery, avec cette fois
une puissance trop faible pour l’endommager.
Le problème est pris très au sérieux. L’inspection
par l’OBSS révèle tout de même un défaut
sur les tuiles à l’avant de la navette.
Une fois amarré à la Station Spatiale Internationale,
Stephen Robinson réalisera des réparations
lors d’une sortie spatiale, ce qui donnera
lieu à ces photos extrêmement détaillées
du dessous de la navette.
Suite à l’accident, la société Spacehab,
concepteur du module d’expériences, demandera
un dédommagement à la NASA pour la perte
de son module, à hauteur de 87.7 millions
de dollars. L’agence ne versera que 8.2
millions comme prévu dans le contrat initial,
et même si la firme annoncera d’abord poursuivre
la NASA, avant de renoncer. Avec l’abandon
des missions de navettes en dehors de la construction
de l’ISS et de la maintenance d’Hubble,
Spacehab ne fournira plus de module de recherche
à la NASA, et les Spacelab européens seront
également cloués au sol définitivement.
Sur un plan plus décent, les astronautes
de STS-107 rejoindront les grands noms de
l’exploration spatiale américaine, dont
Neil Armstrong, John Young ou John Glenn,
en recevant la Medaille d’Honneur Spatiale
du Congrès. Parmi les 28 astronautes l’ayant
reçu, 17 l’ont reçu de manière posthume
: les équipages d’Apollo 1, STS-51L, et
STS-107. Ilan Ramon, israélien, sur STS-107,
est de fait le seul non américain à recevoir
cette décoration. Une partie de son journal
de bord sera retrouvé et restoré, aux cotés
d’un disque de Yehuda Poliker, nommé Dust
and Ashes. Comme un signe, seuls 4 mots sont
lisibles : Dust and Ashes, Ilan Ramon. Son
journal est aujourd’hui en partie exposé
en Israel, et des extraits sont disponibles
dans certains livres. Son fils, Asaf, s’engagera
dans l’armée de l’air israélienne, et
comme son père, tiendra lui aussi un journal.
Il trouvera la mort dans un accident aérien
lors d’un exercice. Doté d’esprits penseurs
et rêveurs, père et fils lègueront des
écrits émouvants sur la poursuite de leurs
rêves de voler. En 2004, le rover martien
Spirit se pose dans le cratère Gusev. Sur
l’horizon, 7 collines se dessinent. nommées
Columbia Hills, chacune d’entre elles porte
le nom d’un astronaute de STS-107. Leurs
noms et le patch de la mission apparait également
sur l’antenne à haut gain du rover.
En 2011, Atlantis est la dernière navette
à se poser en Floride, et met fin à l’ère
des navettes. Aujourd’hui, elles sont exposées
un peu partout aux Etats-Unis, et en Floride,
Atlantis est là, portant encore les stigmates
de sa dernière rentrée atmosphérique. Sous
ses ailes, un mémorial a été crée pour
les équipages de Challenger et Columbia,
et deux débris sont exposés, l’un de Challenger
à gauche, et la structure du pare brise de
Columbia à droite. Le reste des débris est
entreposé dans le Vehicle Assembly Building
du Kennedy Space Center. Quant au bras robotique
de Columbia, retiré avant STS-107, il est
aujourd’hui exposé au Musée de l’Aviation
et de l’Espace de Canada.
Chaque début d’année est organisé le
NASA Day of Remembrance, un jour où l’on
commémore la mémoire des astronautes d’Apollo
1, de Challenger et de Columbia à travers
plusieurs lieux. A Titusville, située tout
près du Kennedy Space Center, j’ai assisté
au Remembrance Day de 2018, qui s’est déroulée
quelques jours après la cérémonie principale
au Kennedy Space Center en présence d’astronautes.
A Titusville, il y avait moins de monde, mais
étaient notamment présents Winston Scott,
astronaute, et Lowell Grissom, frère de Gus
Grissom, qui a péri lors de l’incendie
d’Apollo 1. A Sand Point Park, un mémorial
se tenait là, avec une plaque pour chaque
astronaute tué lors de missions spatiales.
Une cérémonie émouvante, qui fait prendre
conscience de l’esprit de conservation de
la mémoire de l’histoire spatiale américaine,
tout comme le nombre de musées spatiaux en
Floride Centrale. C’est ce qui m’a marqué
le plus là bas, leur volonté de conserver
tout ce qui touche à l’histoire spatiale
de leur pays, et le faire avec dignité. C’est
un bel hommage à ceux qui ont perdu la vie
dans cette grande aventure qu’est l’exploration
spatiale.
Même si la navette fut détruite lors de
la rentrée atmosphérique, la majorité des
expériences ont survécu à la mission. L’une
d’elles, CVX-2, avait été embarquée sur
la mission pour étudier la manière dont
le xénon se déplace en apesanteur. Le disque
dur contenant les données a été retrouvé
endommagé mais lisible parmi les débris.
En avril 2008, ces résultats ont permit la
publication d’une étude scientifique, donnant
de nouvelles réponses à un problème de
physique sur les fluides non newtoniens, la
Rhéofluidification. L’expérience d’étude
des matériaux granuleux a été transmise
avant la rentrée de l’orbite, et a été
considérée comme réussie à 60%. Le petit
bidon de métal contenant des vers de terre
a été retrouvé au Texas, et à la grande
surprise des scientifiques, ces petits êtres
ont survécu à la destruction de la navette,
la chaleur de la rentrée, et la chute libre.
Leurs descendants partiront eux aussi dans
l’espace, cette fois à bord de l’ISS
avec la mission STS-134. La même expérience
de biologie a été réalisée sur les vers
de terre, montrant qu’ils ressentent les
effets de l’apesanteur de la même façon
que les humains, avec des conséquences sur
leurs muscles et des symptômes diabétiques.
Enfin, on citera l’essai du système de
recyclage d’eau lors de STS-107, qui aujourd’hui
permet de recycler la majeure partie de l’eau
à bord de la Station Spatiale Internationale,
et permet sur Terre d’économiser cette
ressource précieuse dans les zones les plus
arides. Le travail de l’équipage n’a
donc pas été vain et a permis de faire avancer
plusieurs champs d’études scientifiques.